[Music]
hey did you know the girl from fortnite
has her own video game
that was a joke please don't hurt me
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
i'm adam and the real news is that
horizon zero dawn is free to download
and keep forever
on your ps4 and ps5 from april 19th
and i'm here to remind you to not miss
out on this opportunity
i'll go over the download times in a
moment as they are strange for many
countries outside of the us
but first an overview we play as a loy
an
outcast child who longs to be part of a
tribe in a time which is both
prehistoric
and futuristic over the course of the
game we piece together what happened to
humanity and why mechanical beasts and
robot dinosaurs now roam the lands
not only is this the full game it's the
complete addition
so if you did play horizon but never the
dlc it's time to grab it
for free the huge expansion the frozen
wilds
brings a new area for alloy to explore
brand new skills and weapons to master
and new machines to face there's a ton
more things in the complete edition so
i'll list them in the description below
including new outfits and bows
and even a digital art book for you
video game purists
if you've never played horizon zero dawn
i beg you to try it and it's free after
all
especially if you're a fortnight player
and you want to know why aloy is a big
deal
and also the bow mechanics are way
better in horizon zero dawn
now let's get the download time sorted
officially the game becomes free on
april 19th
but that's not totally the case in the
usa horizon does indeed go free at 8 pm
pacific time and that's the same moment
it goes free in the rest of the world
so technically that's april 20th in
europe and oceana
i'll throw a bunch of times in the
description below to help you know when
you can download this free offer and
there's no strings attached this is your
game forever
as long as you download it before may
14th i'm adam from playstation grenade
i'll keep you updated on all the free
games coming soon
see you next time